in the home of the US auto industry
Michigan residents naturally took to the
road to voice their anger operation
gridlock also spilled out into the
streets of Michigan's Capitol calling
for an end to one of the strictest lock
downs in the United States and a new
beginning for businesses that had been
shuttered for weeks this arbitrary
blanket spread of shutting down
businesses about putting all of these
workers out of business is just it's a
disaster but Michigan is also one of the
fastest-growing coronavirus hotspots in
the nation and governor Gretchen Whitmer
who has banned residents even from
traveling to their own vacation homes
isn't backing down I know that people
are angry and that's okay and if you
want to take it out and send it my way
makes you feel better that's fine I
support your right to free speech and I
respect your opinions I just urge you
don't put yourself at risk and don't put
others at risk either in one of the
nation's newest hotspots South Dakota
more than 500 workers of this now closed
Smithfield pork processing plant have
tested positive for coronavirus and fear
is spreading just as quickly you'd see
very crowded departments very crowded
floors
you see narrow hallways narrow
staircases with no national plan in the
u.s. each state is making its own rules
which means there is no uniform strategy
across state lines the u.s. has a
patchwork of inconsistent laws in New
York people are now required to wear a
mask when out here in Chicago the mayor
has shut down the waterfront so people
can't gather here but South Dakota is
one of five states with no lockdown and
few rules
South Dakota governor Kristi Noem is
making no apologies plant here is
incredibly important not just to Sioux
Falls not to South Dakota
but to our nation and with governor's in
Michigan and elsewhere facing mounting
pressure to reopen businesses some
wonder whether the inaction of
neighboring states will keep the virus
alive and a threat to all states for
months to come
John Hendren al-jazeera Chicago